James what are three things every
filmmaker must watch or read oh that's a
good question
well I'm biased because my favorite film
of all time is Network I think everyone
should watch Network and there's a
couple of different reasons why they
should watch Network the first of which
is it's a brilliant screenplay it's
perhaps the greatest piece of film
writing ever done petit chèvre is Kees
screenplay is not only a student
prophetic but it's also hilarious it had
this vision of what the future could
look like and if you look at today's
media landscape indeed most everything
he wrote about in that film has come to
pass but it also did it in a way that
was sharp and astute and really
character driven I think people should
watch that for those reasons the
overarching themes but also how he
developed his characters Sidney Lumet
one of things that not everyone knows
about him is that in his early career he
started in television live television
and in those days in the 50s of course
there were three cameras maybe four and
when they had to switch lenses they
didn't have a zoom lens so they'd use
primes and by having that experience in
his toolkit when he got older and
started making his films he could
instantly tell you what kind of scene
needed what kind of lens without ever
seeing the lens because he already had
that in his visual memory and that's
another reason people should watch
Network because it is blocked and framed
in such a specific way that's motivated
by character and mode by evade by
performance that every filmmaker should
see why that works because then they
would think more about what they do in
their own work it's not just about
throwing the camera and shooting a scene
it's about thinking about how does the
camera motivate the performance because
that should be your first job as a
director and that you have to do in
tandem with your DP so watch Network the
second thing you should do is start
reading some showbiz biographies I don't
believe in reading film books I've read
a lot of film books but if you're
aspiring to read film books I don't know
if that tells you anything it tells you
about mechanics it tells you about
structure but honestly I think all of us
programmed with a idea of what film
structure is because we watch movies we
watch television shows so instead of
reading about it read about other
people's journeys and how they got to
the place that they've arrived at I
think that's really important and
there's a plethora of those you can read
you don't have to pick one in particular
although again I'm partial to Sidney
Lumet's making movies third thing you
should do and this is the thing that I
think a lot of people overlook and this
is also reading read showbiz trade
publications and books about show
business because as a filmmaker if you
want to be a working professional you're
gonna be working within the framework of
the film and entertainment industry if
you don't understand what executive has
worked at what company and where they're
moving to and what their history is you
may have a very hard time when you sit
down with that executive if you can't
engage them on some of those things and
understanding some of those those issues
for example in 2010 I was at the
National Film Festival for talented
youth with my film followed it's the
largest Film Festival in the world for
people under 23 and Dana Brunetti was
there and all these fantastic producers
and I made a good impression with the
chairman of the CW network at the time I
didn't know he was the chairman of the
CW network but he invited me to their up
front presentation in New York and I
graduated from college the week after so
it was this crazy crazy time and when I
got to the CW afterparty I found out
that I was the only person there that
was not with the network and Tom Sherman
walks up and and shakes my hand he's
like hey I heard about you were here and
I knew Tom Sherman because I do my
showbiz history he was the executive
develop lost Desperate Housewives Grey's
Anatomy he was a huge huge figure in
television and he happened to be working
now for the CW and so I could talk to
him about those things to say you know I
love lost I love what you did with that
and then years later while I'm reading
the book Disney War I get to have more
insight as to the behind the scenes
mecha nations of what went on
and so I think that that's something you
should do because you need to understand
the breadth of it it's not just about
the creative it's just also about the
business and you've got to put those two
things together so watch Network read
some our tainment biographies and read
the trades and read books about what
happens in the business I think what's
also interesting is on a lot of these
entertainment biographies there's a
stall an iceberg that happens and a lot
of these careers and then usually
there's a resurgence from there and I
think that's important too that people
realize that it's not just like oh just
climbing up and then it's all
happy-go-lucky there's a lot of things
that there's pause for reflection and
yes and it's it's constantly about
reinventing yourself and re-evaluating
your career and I think that when you
read and and have mentors it's not just
about reading or attainment biographies
I also think it's important to surround
yourself with experience entertainment
mentors that can help guide your career
you learn about those roadblocks and you
learn how to get past them and move
through them that's not to say that
someone else's roadblock is something
that you're also going to go through but
you might take something from that that
can help within your own because I do
believe that everyone's journey is very
unique there is no clear-cut way to make
it in our tainment there is no way to
get into the business everyone has a
different story and a different path but
when you surround yourself with people
and when you read things that give you
insight before you actually meet those
people then you too can figure out how
to advance your career
you